[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors des élections présidentielles en
mai dernier
35% des moins de 25 ans n'ont pas voté
au second tour et au second tour des
élections législatives en juin
c'est trois quarts des jeunes qui ne
sont pas allés voter
trois quarts en même temps on ne peut en
vouloir à personne
c'est un fait les jeunes ne se sentent
pas représentés en politique alors ce
n'est pas qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas à
la politique c'est bien la politique qui
ne s'intéresse pas aux jeunes
mais comment peut-on prétendre répondre
aux enjeux de demain sans consulter
toutes les générations et surtout pas
celle qui vivra directement les
conséquences décisions qui sont prises
aujourd'hui c'est pour lutter contre
l'obsolescence programmée de la
politique qu'en 2014 une liste
dissidente a été présenté aux élections
municipales dans une commune de la
région parisienne
sa particularité tous ses membres
avaient moins de 25 ans alors 15 % soit
deux conseillers municipaux plus tard
était né à lons enfants le parti de la
jeunesse
j'en suis la présidente et si je suis
ici c'est pour vous proposer le brave
new world puisque c'est le thème
aujourd'hui que nous voulons pour les
françaises et les français
un monde dans lequel les jeunes sont
représentés et participent à la vie
publique
c'est la condition indispensable pour
moderniser la politique et bâtir une
société qui sera capable de répondre aux
enjeux du 21e siècle et surtout une
société dans laquelle l'abstention ne
sera plus le premier parti des jeunes
pourquoi pourquoi
l'abstention est elle si élevé chez les
montres en temps c'est parce que la
politique s'élabore en vase clos
trop souvent loin des citoyens trop de
femmes et d'hommes ont fait de la
politique une rente confortable dont ils
profitent depuis leur bureau à paris
sans aller sur le terrain pour se
confronter aux préoccupations des
citoyens
trop de personnes oublient 4 élus
ce n'est pas un métier c'est un
engagement alors il faut bien le
reconnaître l'élection d' emmanuel
macron à la présidence de la république
a permis d'apporter un peu de nouveauté
et de modernité dans nos institutions
ça faisait un siècle et demi avec louis
napoléon bonaparte qu'on n'avait pas eu
un président aussi jeune donc il faut
bien le reconnaître ça c'est un beau
record qui a été battu par le président
mais on est quand même loin d'assister à
un réel rajeunissement et renouvellement
de la sphère de la sphère politique
typiquement les sénateurs aucun sénateur
la moins de 30 ans la moyenne d'âge au
palais du luxembourg et de 61 ans
comment peut-on tolérer l'absence dans
l'hémicycle de toute une génération de
ma génération mais aussi de votre
génération
il est temps que la jeunesse soit
incluse dans le processus décisionnel
pour que la politique c'est d'abord de
manière inter-générationnelle
l'intelligence collective qui est
nécessaire à l'élaboration des normes
elle ne vient pas seulement de l'âge ou
l'expérience elle vient de la diversité
c'est donc à la génération y de
s'emparer des possibilités offertes par
les nouvelles technologies pour
moderniser notre rapport à la démocratie
et c'est pour ça qu'en juin dernier 58
jeunes ont fait le choix de s'engager et
de se présenter aux élections
législatives avec allons z'enfants je
pense à à paul à jeanne marie à corentin
à morgane tous ceux qui sont sur cette
affiche
tous ont moins de 25 ans et tous ont
voulu montrer que la politique n'est pas
réservé à une élite déconnecté même à 20
ans on peut être candidat à une élection
la démocratie appartient à tous les
citoyens même aux plus jeunes et si on
peut voter à partir de 18 ans pourquoi
ne pas se présenter
alors pour vous expliquer un peu comment
on en est arrivé là
notre cheminement avec ses 58 candidats
laissez moi vous raconter mon expérience
de ces derniers mois le jour où j'ai
voulu m'engager pour faire entendre ma
voix
aucun des gros parti bien implanté n'a
réussi à me convaincre
parce que j'ai vite compris que
sigean rejoignait 1-1 de leurs
mouvements de jeunesse comme il les
appelle concrètement je serai aussi
utile que ça une fourmi et ça ne me
tentait pas de devoir me ranger derrière
le dogme imposé par une machine de
guerre politique
alors je m'étais fait une raison je
m'étais dit que finalement la politique
n'était peut-être pas le lieu de débat
et d'expression que j'attendais mais
j'ai changé d'avis le jour où allons
enfants est entrée dans ma vie dès ma
première réunion on m'a proposé de
rejoindre le think tank le groupe chargé
d'élaborer notre programme parce que oui
je dis bien programme ce jour là je
rappelle que c'était la toute première
réunion à laquelle j'assistais j'étais
dans le salon du président fondateur
pierre quand il prend la parole il nous
dit les gars on se lance dans un pari
fou on va se présenter aux élections
législatives
partout en france qui est chaud alors
sur le coup je me suis dit c'est un
malade
et en effet il était peut-être un peu et
je savais pas dans quoi j'allais me
lancer ce jour là mais à partir de ce
moment là j'ai vécu les mois les plus
épanouissant de ma vie alors d'abord il
a fallu élaborer ce programme donc pour
ça on se retrouvait une fois par semaine
chez l'une d'entre nous ou pour débattre
des thèmes qui nous tenait à coeur
est ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est
vraiment changer la façon de faire la
politique donc à aucun moment on se
demandait s'il allait d une telle
proposition était de droite ou de gauche
mais bien si elle permettait de répondre
de manière concrète à un problème posé
ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est raisonner
plutôt qu'idéologie c est donc pour
faire ça on a bâti notre réflexion sur
quatre thèmes l'innovation l'europe
l'écologie et l'éducation
pourquoi ces quatre thèmes parce que ce
sont les enjeux fondamentaux auxquels
nous devons faire face dès aujourd'hui
mais surtout auquel on va devoir
répondre les années à venir
et pourtant les parlementaires ne
saisissent pas de ces enjeux peut-être
par manque de modernité au pragmatisme
et donc là si vous fermez les yeux
quelques secondes si on y réfléchit
rapidement comment avoir un mode de vie
plus durable comment moderniser
l'éducation comment inciter à
l'innovation
vous avez pas déjà des idées
vous viennent si on a des idées comme ça
c'est parce que c'est m
il nous concerne directement alors ce
que nous voulons c'est moderniser
l'enseignement il est nécessaire
d'adapter notre système éducatif aux
évolutions de l'économie pour donner
toutes les clés en main ou aux élèves et
étudiants français sur le marché du
travail
donc concrètement ça passe par modifier
les cours de techno ont construit des
lampes à led pour y ajouter des vrais
cours de code et d'informatique ça passe
aussi par la création d'un bac pro
digitales et de manière générale par la
revalorisation de toutes ces filières
professionnelles technologique de
l'apprentissage sont plus en prise avec
le marché du travail
pour mettre toutes les chances de notre
côté nous voulons ainsi penser européen
cet échelon nous paraît idéale pour
mettre en place des projets d'envergure
comme un incubateur de start up
transnationales pour créer une silicon
valley européenne avec de réelles
entreprises technologiques à l'adn
européen pour concurrencer les gaffes
américain google apple facebook amazon
ou les géants du numérique chinois comme
ali baba et pour redonner du lien entre
les élus et les citoyens
ce que nous voulons c'est limité à deux
mandats dans le temps le nombre de
mandats consécutifs possible comme c'est
le cas déjà pour le mandat présidentiel
nous voulons aussi imposer des quotas de
jeunes sur les listes des zélés pour les
élections municipales
nous voulons renforcer les sanctions en
cas de non par était non respect de la
parité femmes hommes sur les listes de
candidats et surtout supprimer toutes
les limites inférieures d'âge pour se
présenter à une élection
aujourd'hui on peut pas se présenter aux
élections sénatoriales si on n'a pas 24
ans pourquoi pas bon je pourrais passer
vraiment tout l'après-midi à vous
développer nos idées parce que je suis
persuadé que si la l'union européenne
le notre système éducatif la politique
ne séduisent plus aujourd'hui si parce
qu'on n'a pas demandé leur avis aux
jeunes donc si je reprends le fils de
mon histoire après le programme il a
fallu passer au moment de faire vivre
ses idées
donc c'était la phase de terrain la
campagne en elle-même faire campagne
c'est mettre les mains à la pâte
c'est entreprendre c'est aller à la
rencontre des électeurs pour les écouter
et leur parler c'est
si faire face aux coups bas des
opposants c'est voir ces affiches
déchirées
ça peut-être gribouillée dans la rue
c'est encaisser les coups et se relever
toujours plus fort mais bien sûr c'est
surtout et avant tout aller tracter
alors pendant trois semaines j'étais sur
un marché différent chaque matin un
centre commercial ou autres lieux de
passage l'après midi et malgré la
fatigue s'il fallait le refaire je le
referais dès demain parce que ça m'a
permis de parler à des dizaines de
personnes de tous les âges tous les
milieux sociaux tous les horizons
auxquelles je n'aurais jamais adressé la
parole son ca j'ai même réussi à
convaincre un couple de touristes
allemands dans leur langue s il vous
plaît de voter pour alain enfants alors
bon le petit détail vous me direz c'est
que eux ils n'ont pas le droit de vote
en france certes mais c'est un détail
parce que avec ces personnes avec qui le
courant passe bien qu'ils sont
réceptives à nos idées on peut avoir des
conversations qui sont passionnantes
mais en fait à la réflexion c'est
peut-être encore plus intéressant avec
les personnes justement avec lesquels il
faut batailler pour leur faire passer
nos idées qui nous mettent à l'épreuve
alors là je pense par exemple au jour où
j'aborde une femme d'une soixantaine
d'années
je lui fais mon petit topo sur sûr à nos
enfants la jeunesse ça elle me coûte
elle me demande quel âge et je lui dis
que j'ai 21 ans et là l exposé de l'air
mais littéralement elle était mort de
rire
elle a rigolé tellement qu'elle
n'arrivait plus à parler et on trouve
deux éclats de rire elle me dit on mais
les madmoizelles mais vous avez l'air si
j'ai tout fait 14 15 ans pas plus pour
ce n'était pas très agréable sur le coup
mais je pense que c'est révélateur
ça prouve que on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir des candidats jeunes comme si un
vent de fraîcheur on n'avait pas de
cerveau en état de marche comme si on ne
pouvait pas avoir des idées
c'est ça qu'on veut changer avec allons
enfants on veut prouver le contraire et
donc au final est venu balle
le jour du scrutin le jour des résultats
je vais pas faire durer le suspense plus
longtemps et j'ai obtenu et 0,5 pour
cent des votes soit 200 bulletins
quand je suis arrivé au boulot le
lendemain mon boss de l'époque quand je
lui annonce
mon score me répond ah c'est la loose
mais non c'était pas la loose il avait
rien compris parce que ça voulait dire
que 200 personnes avaient voulu soutenir
nos idées nos valeurs avaient décidé de
donner leurs bulletins leur voix de
citoyens dralans enfants il avait glissé
dans l'urne un seul butin le nôtre ça
voulait dire que du haut de mes 21 ans
j'avais réussi à convaincre plusieurs
centaines de personnes du bien fondé de
notre projet et notre engagement et ce
sentiment
j'aurais pu connaître avec aucun autre
parti gros party qui refusent
généralement de présenter des candidats
jeunes et sans expérience
alors non dominique si tu m'entends
c'était pas la mise
je lis la question dans vos rôles dans
vos yeux la question que vous posez et
maintenant le renouvellement ne fait pas
que l'invoquer on le met en pratique
alors après les élections il a fallu
changer l'équipe dirigeante c'est comme
ça que j'ai été élu présidente avec la
mission d'accompagner le parti vers les
élections européennes en 2019 qui vont
précéder les élections municipales
ça nous laisse donc du temps pour
affiner nos idées nos prises de position
et pour encourager la jeunesse française
à s'engager notre antenne de lille a
déjà mis en place des actions de
sensibilisation à la démocratie dans les
lycées parce que notre gros défis dans
les mois à venir ça va être de nous
ouvrir dans deux directions
sociologiquement pour que toute la
jeunesse française soit représentée dans
nos rangs et géographiquement
alors à ce sujet on a ouvert il ya un
mois tout pile une antenne à nos enfants
ici même annoncé son représentant et
dans la salle et je pense qu'ils se fera
un plaisir de vous en parler il souhaite
intéresser
keith algérien pour conclure je voudrais
vous laisser avec un message le message
à nos enfants la sous représentation des
jeunes dans notre démocratie n'est pas
une fatalité
ce n'est pas parce que la politique sont
ne pas s'intéresser à nous que nous ne
pouvons pas nous intéresser à l
au contraire c'est à nous de reconnecter
le pouvoir politique avec la réalité
il faut prouver à la face du monde à la
passante qui marie launay dans la rue
qu'à 18
25 ans on est tout aussi légitime que
n'importe quel autre citoyen pour
s'exprimer et être entendu dans le débat
public
c'est la raison d'être de mon engagement
et c'est la raison d'être de nos enfants
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]